>> And before we get started actually, I'd like to mention that there's
just, you know, FYI, there's different kinds
of verbs because what I'm looking for
is really action verbs. So verb, verbs that clearly express an action that
can tell me that, you know, what, for example, an item could do, 'kay?
>> Okay?
>> Not the verbs that represent, for example, relationships, 'kay?
>> Okay.
>> So, and the, there, and the ones
that I've identified und, underlined here actually, I,
I underlined complete sentences so that you kind of we can look at the verbs in
in context. And the first one is this
sentence that says that the library may need
to know or to calculate the items a
patron has checked out, when they are due, and
any outstanding overdue fines. So I, I will
imagine that this is representing a situation in
which you bring up a patron's record and
you start looking up this information. Is that [CROSSTALK]
>> The, the patron often wants to know what they have currently checked out.
>> Oh,
alright.
>> Or when are their due or how much they're owed or.
>> Oh, in fact, and then now that you mentioned it,
I think you sent me. One of the scenarios you sent
me had to do with that, right, with the patron coming
in and asking for this information. So yeah, and it makes
a lot of sense. So what I'm going to do, I'm going to
model this by adding this three operations to the patron method.
The first one, I'm going to call, itemsCheckedOut and, basically, it's an
operation, but you don't need to, you know, understand the implementation
details, but when you call this operation, it will
give you back exactly this information, so the items
that are checked out by that patron. The second
one, I'm going to call it whenDue. That will tell you
basically when a, when an item is due. And
the third one is going to be called the outstandingOverdueFines and,
you know, as the name says, it's going to tell
you what are the outstanding overdue fines for that patron.
>> Okay.
>> And as you might notice I mean,
I, I'm going to separate the, the, the attributes
from the operations by having a separate kind
of subrectangle so, in this way, it's clear
what is attribute and what is, what is
an attribute and what's an, what's an operation.
>> Gotcha.
>> And let me see then. Okay, for the
second one you can see that that patron can check
out books and audio visual materials. So I guess,
similarly you, you build kind of the record for a patron.
The patron will give you an item and you will record
the fact that the patron is kind of checking it out.
>> Right. And is that operation related to this,
the checked out attribute that we did a minute ago?
>> It is actually because what will happen then again, you know, if we jump
ahead a little bit would be that every time you invoke this operation. So I'm
going to represent this as a checkOut operation
for the patron. Every time you invoke this,
you will also have to say something about the item and so we will also
flip kind of that that, that build information in the, in the, in the item.
>> Okay.
>> Mm, 'kay? And, and finally, here, I can see that
a patron can request a book or an audio video item Is
not currently in. So I guess this is referring to items that
are already checked out but for which there is interest. Is that?
>> Right. So, particularly, the popular items the patrons want to get on
the list so that they get notified when it comes back in and.
>> Oh.
>> And check it out.
>> I see. I see. Okay. Then I'm going to do
the same thing here. I'm, I'm going to add this method,
which I'm going to call request and I'm going to put it
here in the list of the methods in the list.
>> Okay.
>> Of operations for the, for the patron, okay?